Hello, and welcome to today's episode of Rawkode
Live at the Rawkode Academy. I am Rawkode.
That is three of the Rawkodes too many.
Today, we are taking a look at CueBlox,
a actual personal project of mine and a
friend and colleague, Brian Kettleson. We're gonna be
guiding you through everything you need to know
to do cool things with your data.
Please remember to like, share, subscribe, comment to
these videos,
join the channel, and you'll get updates for
all new episodes of Rawkode Live. We also
have a course in flight on InfluxDB,
so check out the options for joining the
academy.
And there's also a rather active Discord server,
over 500, nearly 600 people talking cloud native
Kubernetes, Go, Rust, you know, all sorts of
cool technology things. So come and join us.
Say hello, and I look forward to meeting
you.
Okay. That's the housekeeping over the way today.
Like I said, it's a personal project. Brian
and I have been working on this for
for months and months and months, and I
we're both really excited to share it. Right,
Brian?
This is really exciting. We've been we've been
iterating on this forever,
I think, and
it's starting to become something that feels right,
which is awesome.
Yeah, I couldn't agree more. I think we
talked about it for a while before we
even started building it. I think our conversations
around us maybe started towards the end of
last year, maybe a little bit earlier,
where we both just had these grand plans
for how we wanted our data to work.
And just,
it's been really cool watching this project change
a lot over the last seven
or eight months.
Yeah. I think my favorite thing about this
particular project is the fact that
we've been completely unafraid to evolve
our implementations
as we realize
the way things are working
didn't really meet our visions. And and when
when the the code takes you in the
direction you don't wanna be, it's it's totally
okay to throw that out and and start
over. And we've definitely done that more than
five times.
Yeah. I hadn't I hadn't actually thought about
that. But, yeah, we do we we experiment
a lot. Right? We're definitely tankers always playing
with new technologies and and new tools. And
I think we we kind of take those
learnings and experience and and bring them back
to what we're actually doing. So yeah.
Let let
we kinda skip the step here. For anyone
that's not aware of you, Brian, can you
give us a little bit of an introduction
and tell us a little bit about yourself,
please? Sure.
My name is Brian Kettleson,
I'm let's see My nice little lower third
there. I did text name off. That's it.
You you don't deserve my purple name anymore.
I'm a cloud developer advocate at Microsoft on
Azure, and we focus on
Linux and open source,
all of the fun stuff. So,
I really enjoy my job because I get
to do open source y, Linux y things
all day long for Microsoft
and
surprise people. I guess it's it's maybe less
surprising now than it used to be, but,
you know, Microsoft has a ton of open
source and
we really enjoy
contributing back to the community and and helping
people
with their open source projects running them anywhere,
including Azure.
And our our team is full of contributors
to all sorts of different OSS projects.
Yes.
Definitely not the Microsoft of the nineties. I'm
always super impressed with the work coming out
of Microsoft
over the last ten years. It's it's really
refreshing and it's great to see.
Push,
you're always hacking on weird things on Azure
too. And in fact, there's been a couple
of really cool experiments that you've done with
CueBlox alone on Azure, which I've done really
interesting as well. Like, you just seem to
have this really cool way of being able
to take stuff that should be run on,
like, a real machine and making it serverless
in some way, which is always exciting.
You know, it's so funny because maybe three
or four years ago, I was as anti
serverless as one can be.
Just why in the world would you want
to give up control of your code and
how it's hosted? And now,
I don't want to host anything of my
own at all. It it better be in
the cloud or I'm not gonna run it.
That's just it's it's so weird how
how quickly I changed my mind on the
serverless concept.
And,
you know, I'm I'm I'm totally embracing the
fact that I used to be anti serverless,
and now I'm very pro serverless. It you
know, it's it's okay to change your mind.
It's okay to have new opinions and
and learn.
Yeah. I think the frameworks are also I
I mean, I don't wanna throw into a
pro serverless conversation by any means, but serverless
as a technology has improved so much as
well over the last few years. Like, you
can now take go by any reason or
Java application, Python applications, whereas initially, was really
just here's about JavaScript and we're gonna run
it in some way for you on this
platform.
Yeah. Yeah. It would it's definitely evolved a
lot and it's still evolving. I mean,
most of the platforms
that where you can run
things that aren't JavaScript,
you have to do them over some sort
of HTTP bridge, you know. So it's we're
we're we're way back in the nineties doing
CGI again, and that's okay.
It works and it's fun.
It will evolve more
and that's fine.
Sweet. Alright. So the topic of the day
is CueBlox.
Do you wanna give people the
that Taylor thing is super cool. Do you
wanna give people the TLDR? Have you have
you got a patch ready for it? How
does one do the TLDR of CueBlox? So
CueBlox
as a vision
was
started because we wanted a way to have
a schema for our
data that we could share in a group.
So if if you and I were talking
about an event and that event happened to
be described in a YAML file or a
JSON file,
we wanted to be able to share those
events in our teams and our groups
and be able to reuse them
across
the team
without any crazy translation of, you know, your
field names and my field names. So,
that was the beginning of the discussion that
ended up with us writing thousands of lines
of Go and learning Cue
and,
months and months and hours of work.
And what we've ended up with is
way to define
a schema for a record set and
use that schema to validate your record set,
including referential integrity between groups of records,
and then publish it using all kinds of
really interesting
little tools that we've built along the way
for publishing
and,
share that data
among,
just yourself or among a team with published
group schemas.
We've got a lot going on in in
CueBlox. It's it's I don't know if there
is a TLDR. There's certainly no elevator pitch.
Yeah. I mean, I think, you know, if,
you know, if if if anyone's watching this
and they go, I have YAML data or,
you know, I have JSON data or you
have marked down data with front matter. Like,
if you want to be able to enforce
a schema on that front matter or the
YAML or the JSON, There are certain ways
to do it right now, but none of
them really provide, I feel,
like the platform. I feel like CueBlox is
is turned into a platform to work with
that data. And if I I'm gonna pull
up something that you created on the website
that I just absolutely love. So
The pyramid? The pyramids. There we go.
This is Maslow's hierarchy of data.
I think this pyramid does a really good
job of explaining why people should be interested
in CueBlox. You know, we we start with
markdown and YAML validation. I think that's one
of the things that when you define the
schema and you point CueBlox to it, you
just get that by running a a blocks
validate command and
it just says, yeah, your data is good
or no, your data is bad.
Yeah. And at the basic level, that's a
really great way to do things like validation
for the front matter in your blog posts.
You know, something really simple, you're not gonna
ship a blog post without
a date or a title or an OG
field, you know, whatever it is that you've
got in your blog that is important to
make your website look good. Yep. You you
can use blocks to validate that they're all
there and in the right format.
Yeah. And the
referential integrity, I think, kinda comes in as
there too. I mean, I don't think I've
seen anything else offer that for YAML data,
and I think that that alone is a
great reason for people to be curious or
at least their interest to be piqued. I
I I won't describe that though. I think
when I say reference on Checkatrade, I hope
people understand what that means and we'll we'll
definitely show it as a natural demo in
a few moments.
We then have the ability to convert or
manipulate that that data.
And you've done some really cool things there,
I'll let you kinda tackle that one.
Yeah. We we start with either YAML or
or Markdown and we can convert it into
all
sorts of different things,
JSON being the most obvious and basic of
them.
But,
we built a templating engine into
CueBlox so we can use Go's templates
to
run
any sort of template over either a record
set or individual records. Mhmm. And I've used
that for some ridiculously awesome stuff. I built
a template that builds Bash scripts
and
runs the Bash scripts for each record and
each record set. And it's just I mean,
it's amazing how much power you have with,
Turing complete language.
It's a lot of fun. I can't remember
if we talked about it or you actually
you did it one day, but the Atom
RSS feed, is that something did we just
talk about that? But another that would be
a really good use case for this as
well. Right? No. We we did that. There's
we have an RSS feed.
You
name it, you can build it with the
templating engine. It's
really fun.
Alright. Moving up our pyramid, we have the
shared schemata.
But one of the primitives,
I guess, in CueBlox is that we we
try to provide some functionality for you to
pull in schemata that is stored in a
central location so it can be shared with
other people. And the way that we do
that is just by defining metadata on all
of the on all of the schemata that
gives it a namespace and a type. So
we kind of explore that as we write
our first schema during kind of today's session.
And then a custom schemata repository, I think,
is just really a follow on to that.
So Yeah. If if I can expand on
that though, the Oh, please do. This is
this is really the core of of what
brought us into
CueBlox in building this was getting people on
the same page and making sure that my
definition of an event is the same as
your definition of event.
And once we share the same definitions,
it makes sense to be able to publish
them either privately or publicly.
And so now we have the idea of
creating our own schemata repositories
that we can use,
and everybody points at that repository and our
command line tools make that dead simple. You
know, it's it's as simple as a go
get is in Go,
we can do the same thing for a
schema in in blocks.
Yeah. Definitely. And and some of the really
cool work you've been doing this week actually
moves some of this functionality out of core
and into plugins, which we'll get to have
a really fun look at as well during
today's session.
And the last one is consistent aggregated team
data. So, you know, something Brian and I
have been trying to think about as we
build out this tooling is that, you know,
individual
people may own a subset of data, but
you may wanna aggregate that at a team
or organization
level.
We wanna be able to make that as
easy as possible.
Have I missed anything that you wanna add
to that? No. I
think the core
of where we ended up is the idea
that we have these
federated independent datasets
that share some properties in their schemata
that allow us to aggregate pieces of them.
I mean, my blog
articles may not look anything like yours,
but our event schema are the same and
that means that we can publish an aggregated
calendar
for you and I if we were on
the same team. And the data would would
be perfectly
in in good shape. We wouldn't have to
do anything to that data because of that.
And that's really fun. That that made this
project well worthwhile,
I think.
Yeah. I still enjoy seeing Scamata just for
the record. I think it's a great word.
It is a great word. And you know,
what what what we haven't really talked about
in this whole pyramid is is the
the myriad of tools that we've built
to consume this data and to publish it.
You know, we've we've had a lot of
fun along the way,
building things that make REST APIs out of
CUE data automatically and GraphQL APIs.
And Yep. You know, all of that is
is dead simple and
one GitHub action away. So
David,
from minute one,
has been insistent emphatically insistent that
this is GitOps. You push to a Git
repository and things happen.
And I think that's been a really solid,
goal for us is to have Git be
the source of truth for this data and
then publishing things just happen afterwards.
And that's that's that's where I've had most
of my fun, think, is is taking that
cue data and alright. How are we gonna
make this into
GraphQL
serverless
on for sale or on Azure,
on Google Cloud, you know, and I've had
a lot of fun doing that.
Yes. 100%.
Alright. Before we dive into the hands on
bit and we start actually playing with CueBlox,
I think let's try and
cement everything we've said so far with like
a real world use case for what we're
actually using CueBlox for.
So
I think we'll try and stick with what
we have in common and then feel free
to add on whatever you wish from your
own project too.
But I think as developer advocates,
we we both have
articles that we write that we wanna publish
to our website.
Those articles are typically marked down and we
would now both have them living in a
git directory with a git hub action that
on every commit,
it will validate the front matter on every
article.
And if it passes,
it will output a JSON blob that can
be consumed by other tooling.
That JSON blob is published as a release
artifact on both of our GitHub
repositories.
And
we have
oh,
how are you using your API right now?
I'm using well, actually, I'm using it in
two different ways in the same blog. I'm
I'm I'm pulling it directly out of the
file system in markdown
and using MDX,
and I'm also consuming it over the new
API
The surf command. The
no. Not the surf command. The the static
CDN.
Oh, nice. So that that's the plugin that
I built last week,
which I can show off.
Plugins have been so much fun. Yeah.
I've only been keeping up with what you've
shared with me on Discord, but I'm loving
what I'm seeing. So because we got a
really good demo of that.
So, yeah, your data lives in in Git.
You can validate it in a GitHub action.
You can publish it as an artifact, as
JSON to consume it from other tooling. We
also provide helpers to serve a GraphQL API,
and all just kinda works really nicely. So
I'll share my screen again and we will
jump over
to a terminal and maybe we can just
show how to get started with the tool
itself.
So
our latest version, zero seven o, released,
what, two hours ago, three years ago? At
least some point this afternoon. More than that.
Was it? Yeah.
It was
it was pretty early this morning, my time.
Oh, okay. Maybe six or seven hours ago.
Oh, we we don't have a version command
as a flag. There we go.
Nice.
And the way that you would get started
with blocks is first to run a blocks
init command,
which is gonna set up a little bit
of boilerplate
that just tells you where to store your
schema,
assets, the data itself,
and build directory for any intermediaries
or outputs that we produce as part of
the block project.
Yeah. It's probably important to notice that this
is opinionated but completely changeable.
The blocks dot cue file has references to
each of these directories, you can change them
if it suits you.
And that's something that I take
advantage of heavily in my blog. For example,
the static directory
is actually the same public static directory as
my Next JS
blog. So I share the the static directory
between
the blocks repository
and the website
because why not?
Yes. So this is the blocks up here.
All configurable and do whatever you want. But,
you know, we'll we'll stick with the basics
for today.
My Versus code is
crawling today.
Hopefully, that'll be alright.
This is what happens when you use your
development machine and the streaming machine at the
same time. So
the first thing we need to do is
define a schema. So I think we'll keep
this relatively simple for today's exercise, and I'm
gonna cheat and just
have a single schema dot queue file.
And we need to raise some Q. So
for anyone that's not familiar with Q,
I think you're missing out, it's such an
exceptional language for working with constraints across data
and schema together
with some really cool
abilities to like query the document and do
interpolation and stuff like that. I'm I'm really
impressed with Cue, but it's not the focus
of today's session.
But this is a a Cue document and
in order to in order for it to
be a CueBlox schema,
it requires one piece of metadata,
which is something called a schema.
I think it's named. Right? And I'll call
this Rawkode.demo.live.
There we go.
Demo. There we go. I forgot how to
name space.
And a name, this will be my
article
schema. I think we both know the article
spec pretty well, so maybe we'll run through
that and touch on some of the features
as we go.
So that's right away is
valid. CueBlox would scan this directory, read this
file, and say, hey, we have a namespace
and we have schema for an article.
However, we've not really declared any
types, any definitions,
any entities, whatever you wanna call them from
your own background.
Cue denotes these through
something called well, through the the hash or
pound sign depending on where you're from, but
this is called a definition in Cue. So
here I can define a person and I
can define an article,
like so.
Now in order for CueBlox to know that
this definition should be consumed by CueBlox,
we also need to provide
oh, sorry. Data set
tag like this.
And this just requires
I can't remember. Does it yeah. I think
it is required, but you have to set
Want the plural? Yeah. And you can also
provide a supported extensions,
which we'll talk about right now, I guess.
I think this does default to what we
consider
data that we can read, which is what
YAML
YAML and Markdown. And Markdown. Yeah. Perfect. Yeah.
And those extensions are
YML and MD.
I changed mine to add MDX
too.
Alright. We'll just we'll add a few in
just now, and we'll show how that works.
So the plural of person is going to
be people.
And we'll copy this down here. Now,
why do we need a plural?
You wanna tackle that with that tape?
Yeah. Why do we need a plural? Because
English is funny.
Because we store
the data in directories named after the plural.
It's really that simple. Yeah. Yeah. We use
it for the data directory's name. It ties
the clue there still that you don't have
purse persons
would be a directory name. Or if you
wanna expose it for GraphQL, you can
do cool things there too.
Alright.
What does a person have? Let's
do a really simple schema here. Name. Or
name. Alright. Yeah. We'll just do name. We'll
keep it simple.
And
age.
You happy with that person?
No. No.
I would never put an age in a
data field. You could put a date of
birth or a year of birth,
but age is immediately invalid as soon as
you store it.
Because time carries on.
You're
100% correct.
I also used to be a DBA.
Alright. So you're gonna hear that if I
do a title too then. Right? And then
maybe Okay.
And then we have an article,
which we're just gonna give a title and
a body for right now. And then we'll
have a concept of an author, which right
now, I'm just going to do person ID.
So CueBlox has a little bit of magic
logic.
There's nicer ways to do this, but I
think we'll start off with the magic and
that anything with an underscore ID
will automatically be
inferred
as a relationship
to the person type, and we can use
the referential integrity on that data to validate
that it is correct.
So let's run two really quick documents.
So we've got the plural name here, so
that's going to be people
and we'll create another directory under data called
articles.
And I'll create one in each.
I don't know if we ever changed
this,
but the ID
is the file name. Is that still correct?
Yes. The what you would consider to be
the slug,
the the first part of the file name
is the ID.
Can you see my Versus code is telling
me that the markdown extension does not understand
backspace or on key enter.
And I cannot delete or press return.
Maybe you should kill that extension. Yeah. I
think I will be disabled in the markdown
extension. That is particularly weird.
And I'm pretty sure that's a baked in
one. That's not one I install. Right?
Well, you really made Versus Code mad. I'm
not sure why. That Docker running. That's normally
what happens.
Now you've got some markdown stuff installed there.
Oh, no. Those are No.
Not the installed ones.
You can do
how'd you do the weird search? Is is
installed colon true? That's really struggling. I don't
know. I'm gonna use Vim.
Okay.
Data
people
Rawkode. Okay.
Comment from Kevin in the chat. Did I
break something again? It's not even Thursday yet.
My computer has just been technically unhappy with
me lately.
I'm not unsure why,
and this definitely
hates me.
So this is a markdown fail,
so we just need to indicate that it's
front matter.
In fact, I'll just change that to YAML
because then we can show the body
processing that works in CueBlox, which we haven't
covered.
I'm gonna modify our schemata slightly.
In fact, yeah, doesn't matter because we support
both.
So we need to rename this to data
people raw code dot yaml. Okay. And we'll
add one more, which is going to
be
our article,
which will be helloworld.md.
I don't have any more than don't have
any react stuff, so we'll just do that.
Okay. And this requires a title. So hello
world and a body, and the body will
automatically be inferred
from
what comes after the front matter and the
document.
Now as long as I haven't messed this
up, but I'm sure Brian would be in
there quick if I had, we should be
we should be in a position now where
where we can run block build on this
directory.
It'll load the schemata. It will validate the
data, and it'll tell us it was good.
And it it worked. Okay. So what actually
happened there plugins. That's so sexy.
The plugins are pretty great.
Yeah. I'm really happy with that. Oh, we
just just added those. We didn't add the
author.
Did we
okay.
I've got a typo there, but hopefully this
still works. Good.
Okay. So I've now
contrived the situation where the data is incorrect.
Now the BlogsBelled by default does not handle
referential integrity,
but you can see from what I have
in data
people Rawkode
and my ID,
so what I've used to reference this entity
as the filename of Rawkode.
However, under articles and then hello world, we
have person ID, which is loaded magically as
a relationship
should fail.
And we can pass the dash I flag.
Oh,
it worked.
Does it not do relationships without the relationship
tag?
Did we remove that? I think I made
it I made I think I made it
before. Alright. We're just gonna pretend
that that gave us another message and said
that ID doesn't exist.
Oh, add the relationship tag and show it
works. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
Brian and I weren't happy with that approach
anyway. Because when you expose this data to
other tooling, it also has to be aware
that person ID
is a reference to some entity called person.
And in my GraphQL API, I actually want
it just to say author,
like so,
and still work. Now the way that we
do this through CueBlox is by using an
attribute
called relationship
on our data and telling it the entity
to join the thing too.
So I'm gonna go out on a limb
and break this again and and and just
hope that something that I've written here works.
So now we have Just
you can add that relationship tag in the
data?
I thought that has to go in the
schema.
You are correct.
Thank you.
Or should we run a block spells and
see what happens anyway? Because now we have
a field that shouldn't be there. Right? Correct.
Why is we not getting our messages?
What's your schema look like?
I'm going to set it to 23. Give
me one error message.
I've broken something.
I'm just going to keep playing.
Okay, let's modify my schemata now.
And we're going to now say that we
actually want this to be a relationship
to a person
and we don't want to use the magic
IT thing.
And we'll go with author.
Okay.
Oh, we're not getting any error messages at
all.
Dataset
name and namespace. Pull up your schema again.
There's gotta be something wrong with the schema.
The builder effect's okay.
Oh, we're not getting the article. Okay. No.
Something is wrong.
My plurals
are lowercase
in all of my I don't know if
that makes any difference,
just looking at my data compared to
okay.
Build data schema static.
Schema.
Maybe supported extensions as required.
Let's find out. It is because if
I I can think of the line of
code in my head if it checks to
see if the extension isn't in support supported
extensions,
it's not gonna happen.
And then what do we have in build?
Okay. So it's not that. It's definitely me
broken something.
Maybe I should just jump to the dog
fit repository.
And change the plurals to lowercase, see if
that makes any difference. Maybe it won't, but
Yeah. I don't think it
it shouldn't matter.
Data set,
portal,
ported extensions.
Then data.
Oh, no. I made it worse.
Someone stop me typing. I mean, come on.
Wait. Don't you need
can you
person.
Alright.
Okay. So now we don't have articles. So
I've I've got it closer.
Why are my articles not being loaded?
I'm gonna copy
this. I must be doing something really
silly.
Yeah. I didn't want the right extension. Right?
Phew.
Okay. So
supported extensions
was required. Then I spent then I spelled
it supported extension, and then I got it
right, but doesn't include MD for it to
load the file. I'm gonna go out on
a limb here. Right? And I'm gonna I'm
gonna go back to the magic
first.
All right. Let's see.
Okay, so person
ID
lock, oh no, I need to update my
data.
I thought I could leave that.
What'd you think my notes are here? Is
it gonna work?
I don't know.
It does. Okay.
So everything works as long as I am
not an idiot.
Okay. So this is our our let me
go back into our schema because I I
know I typed a lot there very fast.
Right now we have author with the relationship
attribute commented out. It has no longer been
listened to or
adhered to by CueBlox.
However, we have the person ID and the
elephant underscore ID as a magic relationship. It
will be inferred to the type where a
person, lowercase version of the definition name here.
And what you'll see in my data where
we define the article is that we define
person ID as Rawkode.
And when we run the blocks build with
the dash I, so the dash I just
means verify
the referential integrity and we can ignore this.
This is that field that shouldn't be allowed.
It says that we have a referential integrity
failure because data articles and then the hello
world article,
the person ID does not exist as a
person,
which is perfect. So now if we come
in and we fix this
and we say you are Rawkode and
we build it again with referential integrity, things
will work. However, we've now got a field
error that we don't want. So
we'll remove the magic. We'll go back to
our schemata,
and I'm gonna bring back the less magic,
but the one that is more flexible with
regards to the naming of the field So
we can use the at syntax in Cue
to define a relationship
where the entity or the definition is a
person.
Yeah. And just to be clear about that
at syntax, that's just a tag in Cue,
and we're using it as arbitrary metadata. So
we're
creating a tag in that definition
and
because the tag is relationship,
we're treating that data a specific way. There
is no
there's no relationship
thing in queue where we built that code.
We did build that, which is probably why
I'm having so much problems now. So now
it's telling me that my author doesn't exist.
It's
at relationship. Right?
It's at relationship
and then capital
person.
That's how
mine work.
Yeah. Try that. It told me to go
away.
What have I got wrong? Oh, that's fine.
I actually do have a referential integrity. Oh.
I am making an absolute new Every
time.
Again, when you do things right, they just
work. Okay.
So we have a schema. We are defining
two types within the system and we can
see how adding data to this
works, validates integrity.
And we could take a look at the
build output,
which build,
I need to cat it and then put
Or I can get a second and put
it.
And we get this JSON blob at the
other side. You'll see the body is automatically
parsed through the markdown and the front matter.
So that works together really nicely.
The ID and the author are all joined
there. So that's another JSON
payload that you can work within your application
to consume all of those types and you're
got this guarantee
that any references to other types within the
system just
work.
That
was a lot harder than it should have
been.
Yeah. And this this for the first couple
months, this was our
our
the the extent of our output. We we
output this data dot JSON file,
and that was what we use to build
and and populate everything else everywhere else.
But only recently have we exposed the Cue
database,
as an API so that we can use
other tools
to read that database once the
validation has been completed. And that really changed
a lot of things. That that's what allowed
us to do GraphQL
and HTTP
servers
without exporting the the data to JSON format,
which saves
IO and time and processing power.
Alright. I will show the surf command, and
then I'll hand over to you for all
the fun stuff, if that sounds good to
you. Sure. Nuno has jumped by the chat,
someone we we both know. Pass him by
to see how amazing you both are. Thank
you, Nuno. I appreciate that.
Okay.
I guess I could well, I run GraphQL
and and Dogfood or rather than my my
cellular data here.
We have relationships and stuff there, don't we?
Yes. There's lots of relationships in Dogfood.
Okay. So we actually this is one of
Brian's really cool initiatives. Oh, there's some work
I've been working on.
Stash it.
So Brian,
you built the docs with the pyramid and
you did that all for CueBlox, which I
think is really cool. So
I'm gonna run a blocks build here
and you'll see we have a lot of
different types.
Do we stall your dog food,
schemata.
So we have a concept of an article.
We have categories. We have images. We have
pages, profile sections, and websites. Literally, our entire
website is defined
through
CueBlox.
Articles here, and we've got some really cool
stuff, I guess, we could talk about. We
have the ability to template through attributes.
So you can actually use the Block CLI
to generate new YAML
and markdown files and use the templates as
initial values.
Cue allows you to set default values.
We have our relationships here.
You can even have lists as well.
One more that I think is maybe quite
interesting is
do
profile.
Profile has multiple types. So you can see
you can define a Twitter
account, a GitHub account, a miscellaneous social account.
And then social accounts can actually have an
arbitrary list of any of those types.
And so really cool use of it kind
of enumeration types within queue.
And we can actually generate the Twitter URL
from other parameters within the queue value itself.
And you can see we interpolate username into
twitter.com.
So the dog fit directory, if you just
wanna learn what we're doing with CueBlox is
probably one of the best ways to do
it.
Let's run Blocks serve. So what Blocks serve
does is validate all of that data,
generate a GraphQL schema,
and then serve it for you over HTTP.
So you'll see here, we have a server
running on 8080,
and that's that pop over here.
And what's really cool is that if you
don't want to use the
don't go to HTTPS. Just go to
oh, it's redirecting.
Is that Firefox been really annoying?
Could be.
That's one Firefox. If you use 127001,
will it do the same?
Oh, I think it's just because I'm not
doing
we serve on
GraphQL.
Yeah. But Firefox keeps putting that HTTPS in
there because it's a word, not a number.
Where does that
GraphQL thing live again?
It's configurable.
I just can't remember.
I should be more prepared.
Positive story.
Looking at the code.
UI. The GraphQL UI is under slash UI.
Thank you.
Which makes perfect sense. Right?
I'm sure I did that.
Well, there's more than one. There's this one,
which is the
kind of fancy UI, the playground one, and
then there's the graphical one, which I can't
remember where we made that live.
However, we should be able to say, hey,
I want all
articles
and then use my all complete. So you
give me the title,
the body,
and let's get a nested attribute. So we
want a profile
and we want the first name and the
last name.
And then if we hit go,
we get all our data back over GraphQL.
And I think this is just amazing.
It really is. I gotta make a huge
shout out to you. You plumbed so deeply
into the depths of Cue
to make this GraphQL handler work, and I
still have zero clue
how it works.
This is all you, and it's some of
the most amazing code I've seen put together
in a long time. So kudos. This is
really awesome.
Thank you. I've I've never blushed on my
own stream before, so there you go. You're
responsible for that.
Well, turning YAML into a a full GraphQL
dataset, that's not a small feat.
Yeah.
And we'll highlight some of your work with
that because I I'm not I'm not gonna
let you pull credit this way. But this
also works with serverless, but not with the
serve command. Right? Because users work with Azure,
Versal, Netlify.
I think there was one more where the
there is a static GraphQL JS library that
can serve the build output, the build artifact
from a blocks build over GraphQL too. So,
like, you don't want to run servers, you
can still make this work. However, you will
lose access to the relationship attribute, but Brian
and I are working on that too.
Or you can use the block server command,
which builds the schema on the fly for
you.
And it you can also run blocks serve
in all of those serverless environments because all
of the ones you mentioned support Go.
So that's that's not hard at all. In
fact, I have a repo somewhere.
I don't know. I've got so many repos.
I've got an example of that somewhere.
We can dig it up when we're we're
doing our show and tell. Alright. Sweet.
Alright. Well, that is
that's CueBlox as its basics. We can initialize
in your repository. We can very quickly using
Cue define our schemata. We can define the
types within that schema.
We can start to generate data. There's data
data.
What was the command from that? We've got
a lot of commands. Let's list them.
And there's
new, which allow you to template. So generate
new data, YAML files or Martin files based
on the schema itself. The remote commands are
managing this schemata. The render one is really
cool, which Brian's gonna maybe Yeah. Renders are
small, so that off. And plugins,
which I
I don't know anything about. I'm gonna I'm
gonna I'm gonna throw that over to you
to to do that justice.
I snuck those in under the fence this
last week and David approved them. I think
you read the code though, let's be honest.
Yeah. I think we're in a position where,
you know, we were adding a lot and
you you raised us
a week ago, maybe two weeks ago that
we we just got a lot of code
and we need to find a way to
make this
to extract some of it and make other
make it easier for other people to also
contribute plugins.
Yeah. If you wanna pop your screen off,
once that's there, I'll jump over to our
other screen share mode and we can show
off plugins and render.
But if you have if you're watching, you
have questions,
you're curious about maybe you have a use
case for CueBlox and you wanna know or
you want us to confirm that, yes, that
would be an awesome way to use it,
jump into the comments. And if anything I
have covered you want a bit more detail
on, just drop that in the comments too.
Is that screen share coming?
It's coming.
Is the computer behaving badly?
Oh, Edge wants to control my screen or
share my screen, and I have to remember
what my password is.
It's then gonna ask you to restart Edge,
which you don't have to do. You can
just say no, and it still works. I
do that a lot. Good.
Later.
Alright. So I'm gonna do a window,
blocks.
I cheated just a little bit, and
I put
ton of projects into one workspace
so that we can show them off differently,
separately. Your Versus code is now live, so
feel free to to take it away.
It's live? My Versus code works.
So
we've got that as a starting point here.
This is a working Versus code. And even
if for some reason I could have the
strange problem where backspace didn't work, I use
Vim key bindings,
so I could just d d and get
rid of those files.
Yeah. Show off.
Yeah. Well,
it's not so much a show off. It's
it's muscle memory. And I blame Eric St.
Martin for that. You know, twelve years ago,
he's like, you need to learn VIM.
And once you learn VIM, it's really hard
to unlearn VIM.
Alright. So,
one of the things that I built very
recently is the idea of plugins. We have
we have a ton of commands. Let's look
in our internal command directory here. There's a
ton of commands. And I was looking at
the the code that manages the remote repository.
So
blocks build and blocks serve and blocks render,
that's all
use in your local repository. But then we
have this whole concept of
a a schema repository that you can create
for your company or your group or your
team.
And there's a bunch of commands that manage
that, and it feels to me like that
code doesn't really belong in the same place.
It doesn't belong polluting our
blocks help file.
It it should be somewhere else. It should
be a plug in. So I went down
a total rabbit hole and found the HashiCorp
plugin
code. Let me see if I can show
an example of that.
And I'm really impressed with this go plug
in package. It allows you to create an
interface, to find an interface.
And in the interface
is just a contract between the caller and
the thing that's called
and it uses RPC
or gRPC
to talk
between the the server and the client,
and it it could not have worked any
easier.
So I I I thought about it, and
for the basic use cases, we really have
kinda two things that we need to do.
We need to have,
things that happen before the build and things
that happen after the build. So I created
prebuild
and postbuild
as
plug in interfaces.
And then the
GoPlugin package has this concept of a magic
key and a magic cookie,
the key and the value. And those are
just handshakes that that let the, the client
and the server know that they're both speaking
the same protocol and and they should be,
talking to each other. And and like the
comment says, this is not a security feature.
This is more of a are we speaking
the same language and and should we be
talking to each other kind of feature. So
we've got these,
handshakes configured and the interface is configured. It
made it really easy to build plugins. So
let's take a look at,
the first plugin I built
is blocked images.
And I am obsessed
with serving the right size images for the
screen that's on on display
and being able to use
the height and width fields in my image
tags.
So I built this plugin
that reads all of the files from the
static directory and that's declared in your queue
or your blocks dot queue file.
And it goes through and
uses
this
where is it?
Imaging dot open. So it reads the reads
the file. If it's if it's an image,
it reads the file
and then,
modifies the YAML or actually creates YAML,
excuse me, with a
file name, the height and width and then
potentially a CDN endpoint which would be a
prefix for the URL.
So because this is a pre,
plugin,
we're actually creating,
data
that will then be compiled and built by
CueBlox.
So let's look at that in practice in
my blog.
I've got my blocks dot queue
in the root directory of my blog.
And you can see my data and schema,
all these directories are a little bit different
than the demo that David showed because I
want to be able to share these directories
among,
both CueBlox and the blog itself.
So specifically, the static directory is public static.
And that means that when CueBlox runs,
it's gonna be looking for static files in
that public static directory, which is the same
static directory that
Next uses when it's serving
images. So I've got all these images in
my public static directory.
If I open up a terminal
sorry. I'm on a strange keyboard.
Where's the terminal thing? Here we go.
I put away my loud keyboard.
Yeah. I can hear you typing there. That's
that's different. I like it.
Get rid of my custom
built blog or blocks and make sure that
I'm using the one that I brew installed.
Oh, by the way, Blocks is available on
Homebrew.
You can use that on Linux or Mac
OS.
So if I do a Blocks build,
what it's going to do is
run those plugins. Let's go back to my
Blocks queue. There's a pre build section with
an array of plugins and a post build
section with an array of plugins.
So I've got a plugin called Blocks images,
and the executable is Blocks images. Let's make
sure that exists.
So
if I type box build,
it's modern. Oh, I need to be in
the data directory.
I do?
It said that your data schemata directory didn't
exist.
How can that be?
Where did it go?
It it's really gone too.
Git restore.
How about that?
Uh-oh.
Yeah. That's frightening.
Where's the schemata directory?
I bet it got moved.
Sections. Look at that. See? It's schemata. It
got moved. I
do that all the time on my laptop
somehow. I fat finger and move things.
Alright. Let's see if it's back. Oh, it's
back. Good news.
Alright. Let's try that block build again. There
we go. So sir. You see that it's
running the plugins.
It registered the blocks images plugin.
It initialized it, and now it appears to
be doing nothing. But what it's actually doing
is
blowing up
because the post plugin isn't there, but that's
okay.
The pre plugin actually ran.
And if you look at the public static
images directory,
you can see this directory structure and a
bunch of images. And now we go back
up to my data directory,
and you can see that my my prebuild
plugin
created YAML files for each of those images
that has the height and width and the
file name.
And because it has those,
now in Next. Js in the templates for
my
my website,
I can specify
the
the image information
directly from that slug or directly from that
YAML file
and,
get the nice pretty image
tags from Next. Js that does
the responsive image sizing.
Very cool. I like that. Right. This is
the most talking I've done in three months
since I've been on paternity leave.
Yeah. I've done a lot of nursery song
singing, though.
Yeah. You've only been back, what, less than
a week, and I've already dragged you in
front of the camera to do a stream.
So, you know Just a couple days. Yeah.
So
that's the prebuild plugin. It creates all of
these YAML files.
And then if you look in the build
directory here,
you can see individual data files because that's
another thing I added recently.
Instead of just a single data dot
JSON file, which still exists,
I also break them out into,
both
record set level data
and then individual record data so that I
can serve them from a CDN, and that's
part of my post build process. So that's
a great segue into
plug in number two,
which is static sync.
Static sync
takes the output
either in the images
or the data that's built and syncs it
up to any CDN or cloud bucket
that's supported by go go cloud. So in
my case,
it's using Azure's
blob storage with a CDN in front of
it.
Bucket missing.
I must have
Did you use DRAM when you went into
that directory? M r c. Well, I just
have to be careful not to
give away keys here.
Edit bucket. We should be there.
Bucket missing.
Oh, I might not be signed in to
Azure on this machine. I do most of
my development on a different laptop. So Uh-huh.
Possible that I'm just not signed in.
But what this plug in does is
it's actually
a good example of that interface,
that plugin interface being used twice.
So
in the main, I've got two different plugins
defined in the same binary here. So I've
got the static sync plugin and the data
sync plugin,
and those are each in two different Go
files. So the data sync plugin
reads the build directory,
that output directory that has the data dot
JSON file.
And the static plugin reads the build directory
for the stat I'm sorry, the static directory
for our images and and other files.
So
by setting a couple environment variables and running
this plug in, the output gets synced to
two different buckets up in Azure storage, which
are fronted by a CDN.
So you can go to images.brian.dev/images
and get all of the images that,
are in this static directory.
But also the build data
gets output
as well.
So instead of wasting any time running blocks
serve or spinning up some sort of, Node
JS server or anything else like that, I
can now just call images.brian.dev/data/articles.json
and get
the latest
articles
as JSON file,
and they're
cached with an appropriate time to live,
and the build,
process automatically kills the,
CDN cache
when I rebuild it. So a really awesome
and great way to take advantage
of
cloud storage
and run one less server.
So those are the two plugins.
I'm sorry. Go ahead. Yeah. I I
think what you know, just to
clarify
is that CueBlox doesn't try to be too
opinionated on what you do with your data,
but instead open up pipelines for whatever you
want to do with your data. Like, we
have completely different
ideas of how our data works on our
our site, but CueBlox is still the critical
bit of infrastructure in the middle that allows
all of those pipelines to happen, which I
think is just, you know, I think we
got the experience just right with a lot
of that. Yeah. I agree. And and that
was because of all of the
meeting in the middle about how things should
work.
It's flexible enough that it handles both of
our unique
styles of of serving and and consuming data
without getting in the way.
And a great example of that, if you
look at the GitHub workflows
for
the blocks project itself,
in the main,
this is the thing that builds
CueBlox
and runs GoReleaser,
and it also runs
our,
where is it?
Data. Here we go. So this is the
the thing that publishes the data
and then also builds our websites.
All of that
works across the same set of data,
but can push to
any number of different
endpoints.
This particular
GitHub
action is pushing to, Azure static web apps,
but we've also got some in here that
push to,
Vercel
just as an example because we can.
And it's it's really fun
taking that same data,
using it as many different ways as you
want.
Here's another example of that.
Let's see here. I've got this particular dataset.
This is my b k m l library,
and it's actually served by a Go binary.
And this Go binary
has
the
HTTP
and GraphQL handlers
that are built into CueBlox,
and they're served
as
an endpoint,
one for GraphQL and one for REST. But
then I also added a
image handling service that will resize images
and perform,
image manipulation if you want to.
And then also an OG image creator. So
you can pass in,
text and it will automatically create
OG images that look like this, for example,
for Twitter and social
media sharing. So
completely different take on serving the data, and
this particular one gets served by,
Fly, fly dot I o, which is an
amazingly
flexible service for running
stuff. I'm having a lot of fun playing
with Fly. Yeah. Fly's pretty neat. Really impressed
with their service as well.
Yeah. So that's that's a good example of
taking
that same data.
So this is the same it's actually a
copy of the data in my blog. So
it's the same data, same articles, images, whatever,
and it's being served in a completely different
way,
over fly. So
that that lack of opinion in terms of
how to serve the data,
has been a lot of fun.
Alright. Shall we take a look sorry.
I need to ahead. No. It's okay. Just
wanted to show off the templates real quick.
So here's here's another repository.
I've got a lot of these laying around
with
different datasets so that we can
make sure we're not
getting too opinionated about our own datasets and
things work well with other use cases.
So this one, we talked a little bit
earlier about blocks render.
This one has some templates in it, and
the templates
build shell scripts.
So if you look at,
the articles.text.tmpl,
it will run for,
the articles dataset.
So you can see there's a range in
in Go's template format. So for each article,
it's gonna call Azure OG, which will create
OG image,
and that's just a quick Go app that
I wrote that does the same thing as
the OG image we looked at just a
second ago.
So this creates a shell script
that
builds the OG images
and then,
executes it. So this this first one creates
the shell scripts. The second one actually
executes the shell scripts. And I think that's
just so much fun. That's there's so much
power in that,
generating scripts and then executing them all based
on the data.
And then we've got,
that's something I think I was just playing
with.
Here's one that creates OG images for each
of the pages in the website,
and then here's a template for the RSS
feed. That's it. There's there's almost nothing to
it when you think about this. This is
almost all
boilerplate for RSS
and just a tiny little bit of
Go templating.
And So cool. I I didn't have to
write hundreds of lines of anything to make
this happen. I just ran it through the
template engine.
That's fun.
Yeah. Definitely.
I didn't know the RSS one which is
sitting there in your repository. I'm I'm definitely
gonna be stealing that at some point. Good.
Yeah.
But I think it's just really cool the
way CueBlox
gets out your way and just lets you
manipulate the data in this way.
And the
way the render
the render sub command with the templates works
is just,
you know, it's so
simple and yet so powerful at the same
time. And I think that's just the sweet
spot.
I really love it. Yeah. And this this
repository,
this is the b k API repository under
GitHub, b kettleson. This one is
built specific
to deploy to Vercel.
So this one deploys
a Vercel serverless API
using,
the JavaScript
engines.
And let's look at that real quick. Here's
the API.
This uses that JSON GraphQL server we were
talking about just a bit earlier and then
JSON server. These are two
really generic
services that we found
just kinda screwing around on the Internet one
day, and JSON GraphQL
takes data that almost exactly happens to be
shaped like the data that we build
in blocks,
and it serves it as a GraphQL dataset
as long as it follows those same conventions
of using the underscore IDs
for relationals.
And then JSON server does the same thing
except with REST.
So
this is,
20 odd lines of code in JavaScript
that create a an express,
endpoint
with both REST and
GraphQL
and also
image handling
in Vercel.
So lots of examples of
very strongly opinionated ways to serve this data
in
very different ways,
but it's all the same tool underneath. And
that's that's really fun.
Yeah. Definitely.
Alright.
Is that everything we we want to look
at on your side?
Will I pop us back over into, like,
face mode? Or Sure.
There we go.
So,
I mean, we're just gonna we'll wrap this
up though, but I think
this has been a lot of fun. Like,
we haven't really spoken about CueBlox much, like,
publicly or on a stream. You know, we've
just been kind of iterating on it. What
I would like, you know, the audience that
are watching is to to play with it
and give it give us feedback. Like, if
it doesn't fit your use case, we'd love
to know why, and we're still iterating on
it a lot. We wanna add more features.
After what I've just seen from the plugins
that Brian's done, I think we're gonna be
adding a lot more plugins over the next
kinda weeks and months. So maybe we should
try and get together and just do this
regularly as an update to CueBlox, maybe every
other month or like that. But I think
That's a great idea. Yeah. Yeah. I've got
literally
a dozen plugins that I wanna build. I
mean, now that the plugin
engine is so easy to use, I I
can think of just so many different plugins
that I can add without polluting the Blocks
code base, and that makes me so happy.
Yeah. One of the ones I think you
were talking about, and I think I'm really
keen on, I was getting to work sooner
rather than later, is, like, you know, leveraging
all of these cloud databases that have, like,
a free tier. Like, know, being able to
run a blocked build and have that
first validate all my YAML, markdown, and JSON,
etcetera, but then store it at a cloud
database. And I don't need to worry about
the block server, and I maybe just get
access to the Contentful API or the FaunaDB
API or the DataStax,
AstroDB API.
It's just it's just there. Right? Like, I
think that's so many, you know, planet scale.
There's all of these different great cloud databases
that have free developer tiers that would easily
serve any traffic that my blog could could
send it.
And,
you know, these plug ins make it really
easy for us to build an adapter that
that synchronizes our data. In fact, this morning,
I saw
Supabase,
which is, yet another,
Firebase clone
that is hostable
both for them and you can self host
it. And that inspired me because it has
real time
eventing. So you can you can notify your
web clients when there's new data added and
that big kind of fun plug in to
build, sync my blocks data up to Supabase
and
and build my website so that when I
post a new blog post, it gets up
in your face and annoys you and tells
you that there's a new post that you
should be reading instead of the one that
you were reading.
Yeah. That's really interesting. Like, imagine we had
like a pre build step that checks what's
changed since last
build, like using the get history,
and then propagate that through to a post
step that actually fired off those
only publish those changes to, like, super base
or to FunnelDB, etcetera. I'm not sure how
that would work, but I think we could
make that work. I've got faith in you.
Well, I was gonna say maybe it's not
necessary though if we just upsert all of
the data.
I was thinking about deletes.
Oh, yeah. We need to work at that.
Good point. But we we for that our
next session, we'll we'll have that working. I'm
guaranteed about Yeah. We'll link that through.
Alright. Awesome. Well, I hope people are are
interested in CueBlox. I think you like what
you're seeing. Like I said, drop us comments.
We're both really active on Twitter. Both of
Twitter handles are on the screen, so reach
out to us if you need any help.
We're both in the Discord. You can ping
us there. Brian's got these fancy titles. I'm
gonna have to steal that. I don't know
how I'm gonna make that work, but I
want it.
Any last words, Brian, before I let you
go? No. Thanks for having me on. This
has been great, And, this is truly one
of the most fun projects that I've worked
on, in in forever. You know, we've we've
had such a great time iterating
slowly, throwing things away,
and the and the debate we've had about
how things should work has been
really educational, and and I'm proud of of
how this is coming out and how it's
evolved.
I couldn't agree more.
It has been. If if folks check
out CueBlox,
please do let us know what your pain
points are. We we tried to put a
lot of energy into the documentation,
but some of it might be outdated.
You know, if things don't make sense or
if you stumble somewhere, let us know where
so we can get those docs cleaned up
and make it easier for people to jump
in. You know, so much of this is
locked into what we intend
versus what we've written. And, we hate for
people to not be able to enjoy CueBlox
because
didn't spend enough time on docs.
Awesome. Well said.
Alright, Brian. Thank you for joining me. Have
a wonderful day. I'm sure and hopeful we
will do this again soon. Well, thanks again.
Thanks for having me. Bye all.
Thank you for watching Rawkode Live.